madame comme vous le savez mon patient
souffre d'une profonde amnésie il ne se
rappellent rien même pas son nom c'est
moi il ne vous reconnaîtra sans doute
pas
c'est possible que je les retrouve
jamais la mémoire oui c'est possible
pendant longtemps je l'ai cru mort j'ai
mis tellement de temps à faire mon deuil
tu as changé tu sais tu me regardais
pareil la première fois qu'on s'est
rencontré
toutes ces photos toi qui les a prises
ça te rappelle rien
rappelle-toi toi tu es serveur
tu photographes
[Musique]
j'ai apporté ça
je suis désolé que ça se passe comme ça
je vais saisir la justice le tribunal
décidera si vous êtes Julien Delaunay ou
Victor Brunet et vous pourrez refaire
votre vie
[Musique]
je veux pas le perdre une seconde fois
je le supporterai pas
pourquoi vous faites ça pour les mêmes
raisons que vous
on a qu'une seule vie je préfère te
savoir heureux avec elle que malheureux
avec moi
que
[Musique]
tu crois jamais parfois je me demande si
tu fais pas semblant
ne pas te rappeler je peux vous donner
de l'argent vous disparaissez de sa vie
madame Delaunay venez proposer de
t'acheter
moi aussi tu m'aimais
[Musique]